As mentioned, the focus here will be on using Epic Games' own Reality Capture photogrammetry solution.
However, let's spare a thought for AliceVision's Meshroom, which is a free application also available for download.
Meshroom is a very solid solution for photogrammetry work, although it is a bit slower than other dedicated applications.
What's more, it contains many templates that take you beyond photogrammetry work.
For example, it has a template that allows you to stitch pictures together to create 360-degree panoramas.
When generating 3D models from pictures, though, it tends to generate too many textures to make the model practical.
So there may be a bit of back and forth between Meshroom and your DCC application of choice to remedy that.
All in all, it's worth a look if you're in the market for a solid and 100% free photogrammetry solution.
But again, our focus will be on Reality Capture, developed by Epic Games.
Reality Capture's workflow is easy.
Once you have taken the appropriate pictures, you load them in, you align them together and create point cloud data.
You then build a mesh object from this data, possibly adjust that mesh by cleaning it up, decimating triangles, smoothing the geometry, etc.
You apply the appropriate texturing from the available images, and export the model as a 3D mesh, typically as an FBX or OBJ file.
This whole process is very simple, and often achieved with a few mouse clicks.
At the time this video was created, the latest released version of Reality Capture is 1.4, and you can visit CapturingReality.com for information.
Starting with version 1.4, Reality Capture is free to use if your company's annual revenue is less than $1 million.
Beyond that, you would need an annual subscription plan.
You can download the app directly from the website, or simply download and install it using the Epic Games launcher.
The first time you launch Reality Capture, you are treated to a welcome or help page in a single pane interface.
But Reality Capture has many layouts accessible from the top left corner.
The two-pane layout is practical when viewing pictures in 2D mode, or when getting information about the project in 1D mode.
The main large pane is useful to view the 3D information as you work on the project.
This two-pane layout is useful in most situations, but there are others that you may find more helpful in some cases.
To load images, you simply drag them from their location in File Explorer.
Once they appear in the project, you are ready to align them.
This can be done in the Alignment tab or by pressing F6.
It takes a few moments to process, and a point cloud is created.
Essentially, the software finds common or feature points between pictures, and recreates them in 3D in a point cloud formation.
You can use the mouse wheel to zoom in and out the 3D view, and the right-click to orbit around the scene.
Ctrl-left-click allows you to pan.
In addition to the point cloud, you can see the cameras that were used to build the data, in this case all of them.
There is also a bounding box that you can use to process the model.
In the Tools menu, you can use the Set Ground Plane feature to reorient the model if need be.
For that, you can use the numerical keypad to switch to an isometric view.
The 2 key will switch you to a top view, 4 and 6 to a side view.
The Set Reconstruction Region feature allows you to limit the calculations to a given area, thus removing unwanted sections.
The 0 key takes you back to a perspective view.
You are now ready to create a mesh model.
This is done in the aptly named Mesh Model menu, or by using the F7 key.
Normal Detail Mode is generally enough, as it creates a model with detail in the order of a few million triangles.
This process is the longest to calculate, and in this case will take about 3 to 5 minutes, depending on the speed of your computer.
Once it's done, you can zoom in on the dino head to see it better.
There are still a few rebel parts that we need to clean up, but first, switch the 2D pane into an Info or 1D Pane mode.
The info on the pictures is still there, but more importantly, there is a component that lists a 3D model made of over 3 million triangles.
Go to the Tools menu, and use the Lasso tool to select the superfluous triangles at the neck level.
You can use the Ctrl key to add to the selection, and alternatively, you can also use the Rectangle tool to that effect if it's easier.
When done, click the Filter Selection button to remove the selected triangles and clean up the model.
Note, however, that this creates a new model entry in the component, thus keeping a history of your work.
You can compare the models by clicking on the appropriate entry in the component.
Both are well detailed with over 3 million triangles, but maybe you don't need this much.
Use the Simplify tool to decimate that number.
Set your target triangle count, say to about 300,000, which in this case is one tenth the original value.
And process the Simplify function to bring the detail down.
Note the new entry in the component, standing at 300,000 faces.
If you zoom in, you may notice the triangulation is a bit rough.
You can help it by smoothing it out a little.
Exit the Simplify tool and enable the smoothing tool.
You can experiment with different values, but I find that a strong type working on surface vertices and a weight value of 1 works best.
Again, this adds a new model to the stack, and that will be our final one, so make sure it's selected.
All that's left is to texture it, and you can use that feature in the Mesh Model tab or by pressing F9.
A pop-up will indicate a feature still in development.
You can opt to never display the warning again and close the window.
Again, it will take a moment or two before it textures the dino head with data coming from the pictures.
You now have a model ready for export, and you could use the Export feature in the application menu to save the model as an FBX or OBJ file.
In the next video, we look at scanning a model from multiple sides.